[Music]
this is the extraordinary telephone call
where russian opposition leader alexei
navalny
pretending to be a high-ranking security
official confronts one of the men who
allegedly poisoned him
revealing where the poison was placed on
what he thinks are orders from above
in the 10 days since it was published
this video has had more than 20 million
views
but still public reaction in russia has
been muted
even in moscow where support for navalny
is supposed to be strongest
[Music]
one of the few two protests outside the
fsb headquarters
was russian documentary filmmaker vitaly
manski
he was arrested straight away and now
faces charges of participating in an
unauthorized event
he says he's shocked at the public's
um
president putin has defaulted to his
usual line of calling navalny who he
famously won't mention by name
a pawn of western intelligence
navalny now faces a slew of criminal
charges as and when he decides to return
to russia from germany which he's always
said he will
in all likelihood if he does he'll go
straight to jail
whatever the kremlin says that telephone
call and the investigation is a major
embarrassment to them and to the fsb
which to a large extent controls this
country
and it has resulted in a raft of new
legislation being passed through
the state parliament one of which makes
it much easier to brand people the
kremlin doesn't like as foreign agents
and another which makes it a criminal
offence to reveal personal information
about fsb employees
the new year dawns with the virus raging
and the attempted murder of putin's most
prominent opponent
still hanging over the kremlin for now
though the response of the people
so long dulled by the din of propaganda
is to downplay both
dynamagne sky news moscow